[Music]
so what do we know about doctor strange
multiverse of madness as of now
1. there are going to be a lot of
characters and creatures in it we are
going to have quite a few variants of
doctor strange himself including
defender strange zombie strange sinister
strange and the others we will also have
two variants of wonder we will see the
illuminati which will include baron
model professor x and even ultron the
version where it works out so there must
be an iron man as well
america chavez wong and monica rambo two
would have their roles
but along with these characters there
are gonna be creatures like gargantus or
it might be shimagarath who knows
the demogorge the god eater or it might
be the demon sidorak then we are gonna
see one more what we saw in the tv spot
slash teaser called fate it is a monster
that looks eerily like gathon
so who is this monster well there are
two sides that are battling in my mind
right now one side where i really hope
it's gathon an eldritch cosmic horror
monster of the marvel universe it would
be super awesome if this monster slash
demonic god-like entity was finally a
cannon to the mcu
while the other side has its
apprehensions and doubts as to whether
it really is it
so here in this short video we will
discuss the two sides we will talk about
how it could be thorn and also bring in
points as to why it might not be cathon
so subscribe if you haven't already and
now let's get to it
so for the ones that i kind of like
clueless let's have a sweet little chat
about the monstrous cathon
this is the archetypal demon one of the
elder gods created billions of years ago
from the demiurge the sentient life
force of earth's biosphere gathon was
earth's first master of black magic
occupying his existence in the pursuit
of knowledge of things that should not
be he later degenerated into a demonic
being like the other elder gods gathon
feared most the god killer which is the
demogorge or the earth's while egyptian
god adam who also is the creator of the
indian gods of moon knight so fearing
the demogorge catholic created a dark
hole and transported himself later into
another pocket dimension to escape it so
what are the points that tell us that
this creature is really cathon well
firstly as wander and strange will have
extensively used the dark hole in the
coming movie the creator of it would
surely have to be introduced at some
point of time
secondly the design of the creatures
is very much like that of cathon demonic
looking with a killer smile full of good
dental hygiene and sexy red eyes
thirdly since we have already seen the
dweller in darkness being introduced in
shanghai the fearlots of the larger
marvel universe will certainly now have
a bigger role to play in the mcu and
gathorn is one of them
lastly just as in shanghai the voice
that called out for help
or was later seen to be the dweller in
darkness so again the same technique
might be used by kethon to lure in
wander to set him free in the guise of
her helping to free the children of her
and that she lost in the events of one
division
okay so now let's go to the other camp
as to why this might not be gathon
the first point that would inevitably be
the killing point of the other corner of
thought is that there are two of these
creatures in that scene one standing
behind wong and another behind wonder
the entity catholic is not a plural
being he exists only as one so that by
itself will nullify it
another important point is that there
already are too many extra powerful
characters both confirm and rumored to
be in a multiverse of madness yet
another addition will just kill the mood
lastly even though they might not be
cathon they could be
most
probably be the angry creatures created
by cathorn in his image well almost
also known as the elder spawn and were
the elder races that predate humanity on
earth these monsters seen in the teaser
might very well be them and along with
wonder and a brainwashed wong we trying
to summon backathon into the prime of
the cinematic universe
anyway that's all we have for now about
k'thon and that tv teaser spot teaser
thing okay anyway with that we come to
the end of it so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the mind cue family
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam